BEN AARON: In the 1800s, as
engineers searched for cost
effective alternatives
to horses and steam
for powering public
transport, wind,
in the form of large kites,
were seriously considered.
But now after two
centuries of development,
we still don't have
kite powered buses.
But we can do this.
The board flip.
Yes, the butter slide.
A nice fence for a grind.
Watch out for my post turn.
And then there's this.
The roll.
An airborne inverted spin.
Nice work.
See you next time.
That was an advanced
version of a role.
A core kite surfing trick
with plenty of variations.
Kite surfers can front roll,
back roll, roll, and nose grab.
There are all sorts of
ways of mixing it up.
And that wasn't one of them.
To perfect the right kind of
airborne rotation for a kite
surfing role requires a mastery
of angular momentum and lift
force.
Here's the roll 101.
As wind flows over a
kite's wing-like shape,
it generates lift force,
pulling him across the water.
On launch, he throws
his body backwards,
generating just enough
angular momentum
for a complete rotation.
To land, he steers his kite
downwards and ahead of him.
This increases lift force
in the direction of travel,
so he avoids sinking.
It is complicated stuff
to deal with all at once,
so first, let's just
practice using lift
force to get a little air.
OK, We've got that covered.
Now let's add some angular
momentum for the roll.
I said, some.
I mean, he did
get enough angular
momentum for one rotation.
But he didn't have time for two.
OK.
Let's work on the landing.
Now, can you remember
which direction
we need to send that kite?
No, quite the opposite.
He actually aced the
angular momentum,
But if you want to
go in this direction,
like your board,
and your kite is
steered down in this direction,
It's not going to happen.
OK.
Last chance.
Arguably worse.
Lift force in wrong direction,
Too much angular momentum.
Very sinky landing.